among those of us who are specialists in
this area there's a kind of consensus
that
the federalists did not persuade we
cannot prove we cannot identify
one person who was persuaded to vote yes
in a ratification convention
because he read the federalist and was
persuaded so in other words the idea
that you're kind of taught in eighth
grade
and then in high school you know and
then law school
if you do that is well here these
here are these papers that were used to
go out and get the people to support the
constitution
that was their purpose but we don't know
that they did
james madison wrote i mean there's so
much stuff that either he was directly
writing like the federalist papers
that he was editing and a zillion other
things is this a good point to talk
about the federalist paper
we need to leave if you want is there
anything else we should lead up to let
me just say about them
in general that they're highly their
influence is highly exaggerated in the
general understanding
really yes because i told you i've got a
bottle of wine it's called the
federalists
okay it's madison's picture maybe it's
good wine and i i if it's that
uh standard issue uh uh silhouette of
madison i
i it is i celebrate the person who
designed the logo
but the thing is among those of us who
are specialists in this area there's a
kind of consensus that
the federalists did not persuade we
cannot prove we cannot identify one
person who was persuaded to vote yes in
a ratification convention
because he read the federalist and was
persuaded so in other words the idea
that
you're kind of taught in eighth grade
and then in high school
you know and then law school if you do
that is
well here these here are these papers
that were used to go out and get the
people to support the constitution
that was their purpose but we don't know
that they did
and in fact by the time the last of them
was published that is by the time the
last of them was
seen by anybody anywhere eight states
had already ratified the constitution
so clearly there are eight states that
weren't persuaded by at least those last
ones
and then there were there were some
states where none of them were published
in any of the newspapers
and there was no state other than new
york where they were all published
besides which in new york it was not the
federalists that persuaded people to
ratify the constitution we know that for
a fact
what was it well what happened was that
by the time new york came around to
considering and it okay well maybe
people people don't know but the
constitution says in article 7
that the constitution will go into
effect among the ratifying states
as soon as nine states have ratified
whether there are 13 so as soon as
two-thirds of the states were ratified
and what that meant was that each state
was supposed to have like
a state legislative election except it
would be an election just for delegates
to this convention
that would decide one question do we
agree yes or no to the constitution
so by the time new york
uh met there were already
there were already eight states that
ratified the constitution and while the
new york convention was meeting new
hampshire ratified that made nine and
virginia
that made ten new york was going to be
11th
when they had their election in new york
state for delegates their ratification
convention two-thirds of them were
people who had promised
a vote for me and i'll vote no in the
convention
but when they had the convention um they
got word while they were at it that new
hampshire had agreed that made nine so
now it's going to go into effect
then they heard virginia had that made
10. now it's really going to go into
effect because george washington can be
the president
right and so that leaves us north
carolina and rhode island well
if we stay out we're going to have an
independent country of new york north
carolina rhode island
and then the federalists from new york
city had a newspaper published an
article that said
in case new york votes no on
ratification new york city will secede
from new york state and join the union
as a state
so then you'd have the independent
country of upstate new york
and at that point the one of the leading
anti-federalists in the convention made
a speech in which he said
we don't have a choice now we have to
vote yes so notice i didn't mention the
federalist in this whole discussion it
had nothing to do with it
that's really fascinating yeah because i
was going to ask you
before you started answering i was going
to ask you well would the states that
had said no would they have had any
recourse but basically they're saying
they're only they're independent yeah
actually by the time george washington
was inaugurated president in april of
1789
there were 11 states that ratified the
constitution so there were 22 senators
there are 11 states represented in the
house of representatives
two of the 13 states were independent
countries north carolina and rhode
island
and they were treated as independent
countries and eventually they talked in
congress about the question
well what should we do about the fact
that rhode island won't join the union
maybe we should cut off trade with rhode
island
make it a little a little dot on the
north american map that doesn't have
yeah anyway finally because what else
are we going to do rhode island
agreed to the constitution but when they
first had their election in rhode island
about instead of having an election for
ratification convention as soon as the
philadelphia convention ended and said
okay
here you need to ratify the constitution
become a member of the union
rhode island had a referendum on should
we have an election for a convention
and they voted like 90 no we don't even
want to vote on whether to vote no
we just know wow and so when they
finally got around to
uh having it um most people were
they were overwhelmingly opposed to it
but they finally ended up agreeing to it
because what else are we going to do the
other 12 states are already in the
united states
and besides that our staying out means
they're talking about things like
creating the judicial system
recommending a bill of rights rhode
island's got no congressmen they're not
participating in any of this they're
going to end up in the union anyway
so they finally joined notice again this
has nothing to do with the federalist
papers
yeah so i still want to get to the
eighth grade version of the federalist
papers but what would have been the
argument for people saying no at that
point
i guess yeah well
um during the this is going to be hard
for people who are listening to
understand
but in the 18th century if you said
money when i say money and you think of
an image in your mind money
that's not what they thought of they
thought of gold and silver coins
right what that's called specie
and what they had begun to do in rhode
island was print notes
bank what were called banknotes we paper
money
and uh printing this notes is just a way
to inflate your way out of debt
and so there are a lot of debtors in in
rhode island who liked this
printing money and getting them out of
debt so they just kept voting for people
in the legislature who would do this
well the constitution said that a state
could not make anything but gold
or silver currency so in other words if
you join the union you can't keep
printing money
rhode island had this paper money party
that was not going to agree to this
right yeah that's why they put it off
forever interesting so
okay so let's just 17 90
1790 was when they joined the union yeah
it's over a year after
washington was inaugurated all right so
i want to do the eighth grade version it
has nothing to do with the federalist
papers
right okay but that's why that's why i
want to circle back there for a second
okay that's really fascinating and i
don't think most people know that that
they didn't have the influence that we
now
believe them to have right so for the
eighth grade version of this
yeah really he was just trying to get
people on board
signing the constitution that was that
was the general idea yeah but what what
actually was in there like was it was it
a real sales pitch
yeah yeah people that just really don't
know okay what to know about the federal
actually the people who
you keep saying federalist papers and i
keep saying federalist
the term the title the federalist papers
was not given to this document until
1961.
that's originally it was just called the
federalist and the author was
publius which was a pseudonym for john j
james madison and alexander hamilton um
they wrote different essays
and there were two or three where we
think probably best and hamilton
cooperated
yeah but anyway um so that was that was
the compilation
yeah yeah so they put them all together
and it's it's one series under the same
pseudonym
noted i will not make that error yeah
yeah but the uh
the purpose of the series was that
hamilton lived in new york
and he knew as i mentioned a few minutes
ago that they had their election for a
ratification convention in new york and
two-thirds of the people they elected
voted no
so or promised to vote no in the
convention so what do we do about this
at the philadelphia convention hamilton
had been one of three delegates from new
york
the other two left after a few weeks
they gave speeches in which they
explained we were sent here to propose
amendments to the articles of
confederation not create a new
government
one of the two who left was the chief
justice of new york and when they got
home to new york
the governor of new york was entirely
against this right he agreed with him
entirely we're not going to have a new
constitution we don't want any of this
stuff we don't want to transfer a lot of
authority out of new york
and so no we're against it so hamilton
knew
that most people in new york political
establishment didn't like it they had
elections
voted against it what are we going to do
well i maybe i could go directly to the
people
so his idea was to have a series of
newspaper essays
maybe to get voters to change their
minds i'm not going to persuade the
governor or the
chief justice they're both definitely
set
but maybe through a newspaper series we
could get people to change their minds
so it's kind of interesting he he went
to a friend of his name governor morris
the guy who actually wrote the
constitution
so if you think of the expression the
actual constitution you see that fancy
handwriting that's
governor morris's handwriting he was one
of the delegates from new york in the
philadelphia convention i mean from
pennsylvania in the philadelphia
convention
he wrote the constitution hamilton asked
morris will you please help me write
this series of essays for the papers to
persuade new yorkers to support the
constitution and morris said
no i don't write for newspapers so then
he went to another friend of his
former congressman named william door
and he said would you please write some
essays
so dora wrote three essays that were
going to be in this series and hamilton
read them and said
no these aren't good enough so dora
published them as a separate pamphlet
and then he talked to john jay john jay
was actually probably the most famous
new yorker at the time
and jay said yes i'll do it but after he
wrote a couple of them
he got extremely sick he was bedridden
for weeks
and so he ended up writing only five of
the 85 essays so now hamilton's
now what and it turned out that this
this
virginian congressman who had been in
the philadelphia convention madison
was back in new york city where congress
was meeting he was a member of congress
too
and he asked madison would you help me
write these for the newspaper i've got
to do something
and madison said sure i'll do it. so
that's why madison ends up being kind of
second most important author of the
series
the thing about the series is in my book
on madison
james madison the making of america i
devote a lot of space to the federalists
not because it was important at the time
but for two reasons one it's important
now people tend to
even people in congress the presidents
people who are on federal courts
they tend to start to answer the
question
how do you understand the constitution
by saying well here's what federalist 48
says
you know so that's one thing but another
thing is
that this is one of the most important
things madison did even if he
even if no one had read them they're
brilliant so you know
if you have a painter you're writing a
book about a painter and he made a
brilliant painting and nobody saw it
until last week
you'd have a chapter on it because it's
important it's an interesting part of
his life
so i think the fact that madison was
this brilliant political scientist
sheds light on the rest of his career he
had an extremely important political
career besides his
career and his short-lived career as a
political scientist yeah
so that's that's why i paid him a lot of
attention but the point is
and i said before i wrote this book
about madison partly because i thought
his
his significance has been exaggerated in
several ways
one is the federalist it didn't didn't
sell the constitution
actually in the play hamilton is
fascinating and to play hamilton there's
a song where
you know you sold it you wrote it and
all this stuff about hamilton which is
also totally exaggerated
but the same thing goes for hamilton you
know the same series it didn't it didn't
sell it
it's not true they didn't make people
ratify the constitution the two of them
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell